This is a rather theoretical
exercise that has two purposes.
One is to verify that the notion
of convergence in probability
is quite natural and
that it has properties
similar to the notion of
convergence of sequences.
And the second purpose is to
get a little bit of practice
with the formal definition of
convergence in probability.
So what is the statement saying?
It says that if we have a
sequence of random variables
that converges to a
certain number, a,
and this basically means
that when n is large,
the distribution is highly
concentrated around a.
And if we have another
sequence of random variables
that converges to
a certain number,
b, which means that the
probability distribution of Yn
is heavily
concentrated around b.
In that case, then the
probability distribution
of the sum of the
two random variables
is heavily concentrated in
the vicinity of a plus b.
So what are we saying?
If Xn is very close to
a with high probability
and Yn is very close to
b with high probability,
then the sum will also
be close to a plus b
with high probability.
This is the intuitive
content of the statement.
Now we want to
establish this formally.
Before establishing
this statement,
however, it will
be a good practice
to verify a property
of this type
for the ordinary convergence
of sequences of numbers, not
random variables.
So let us do that.
What we want to show is that
if a sequence of numbers, an,
converges to some number a,
and another sequence converges
to some number b,
we want to show that
in that case, an plus bn
converges to the sum of a plus
b, and we want to
do this formally.
So let us start with the
definition of convergence.
What does it mean that
an converges to a?
It means that if I fix
some positive epsilon,
then there exists some
number or some time
such that if we consider
some n bigger than n0,
then an is close
to a in the sense
that this difference
is less than epsilon.
Now this is true for
any positive epsilon,
so if instead of epsilon,
I take epsilon over 2,
this would also be true.
Eventually, after some time,
we will have the property
that an minus a is less
than epsilon over 2.
Similarly, if bn
converges to b, then
we will have the property that
there exists some time-- let's
call it n0 prime-- such
that if n is bigger
than that particular time,
then bn minus b is going
to be less than epsilon over 2.
So after time n0 and
after time n0 prime,
these two inequalities
will be true.
So if we wait long enough so
that both of these inequalities
are true, that
is, if n is bigger
than the maximum
of n0 and n0 prime,
then we will have the following.
We will have that an
plus bn minus a minus b
which, by an
elementary inequality,
is less than or equal to
an minus a plus bn minus b.
Where is this
inequality coming from?
This is a general inequality
about absolute values.
If I give you two numbers,
the absolute value of x plus y
is always less than or equal to
the sum of the absolute values.
So we're using this
inequality where
x is an minus a and
y is bn minus b.
So we have this inequality,
but when time is big enough,
an minus a is less
than epsilon over 2.
bn minus b is also less
And putting everything
together, this is epsilon.
So what have we shown?
That if an converges
to a and bn converges
to b, so that all
these relations hold,
then if time n is
large enough, then
the difference between
this number and that number
is going to be
less than epsilon.
And this is true for
every positive epsilon,
but that's just the
definition of convergence
of this quantity
to that quantity.
And this is the proof of
this elementary relation
about convergence of numbers.
Now let us turn to convergence
of random variables.
We fix some epsilon
that's positive.
In order to show
convergence in probability,
we want to look
at this difference
and look at the probability
that this difference is
bigger than epsilon
in magnitude.
And we want to show that
this quantity converges to 0.
If it does, then we
will have established
convergence in probability
because that's just
the definition.
Now, this is the event that
the sum of the random variables
is close to a plus
b, and we want
to use the fact that xn is
close to a and yn is close to b.
So this is the event
that-- let's write it
in a somewhat different way--
is the probability of the event
that xn minus a
plus yn minus b is
bigger than epsilon
in magnitude.
Now, for a sum of two
numbers to be bigger
than epsilon in
magnitude, it has
to be the case that
either one of them
is larger than epsilon
over 2 or the other number
is bigger in magnitude
than epsilon over 2.
So if this event happens,
this event must also happen.
This means that this event
is a subset of this event.
This is a smaller one.
If this happens, then
this one happens.
So since it's a
smaller event, it
means that its
probability is less than
or equal to the
probability of that event.
Now we use the union bound.
The probability that
something happens
or something else is
happening is less than
or equal to the sum of
their probabilities.
And now, since Xn converges
to a in probability,
then by definition, we know that
this quantity converges to 0
as n goes to infinity.
Similarly, since Yn converges
to b in probability,
this quantity converges to
0 as n goes to infinity.
This is a sequence of
numbers that converges to 0.
This is another sequence of
Therefore, the sum of these two
sequences also converges to 0.
In essence, here we're applying
what we established earlier
about convergence of numbers.
If a sequence converges to 0
and another sequence converges
to 0, then the sum
of these sequences
also converges to 0
as n goes to infinity.
But this is exactly what
we need to show in order
to establish convergence in
probability of Xn plus Yn.
We have shown that if I
fix any epsilon, positive,
no matter how small,
the probability
that I am more
than epsilon away,
the probability that Xn plus
Yn is more than epsilon away
from the supposed
target or the limit,
this probability must go to 0.
And that's exactly what
we established here,
and this completes
the derivation.